anime conventions are a rare nigma where
you can see herds of wild @rq migrate
from the safety of their own homes to a
designated spot in order to socialize
interact and sometimes even breed with
their own kind and can sometimes be
intimidating for outsiders looking at
the strange lifestyles seen at these
gatherings but as I've been to many cons
this year and with Khan season almost
over what is the real experience I think
both new and seasoned Khan goers should
be aware of before deciding to go to a
convention know they can cost a fair bit
of money so budgeting is a very
important skill to have one commonly
suggested budgeting technique is to take
your entire life savings add the maximum
limit to your credit card and now a
combination can be expensive but you can
get around this by rooming with some
friends if you don't have any real-life
friends to room with then the next best
thing is to find online friends they're
like real-life friends except you're
more familiar with them as a disembodied
avatar on your computer screen just be
careful as you shouldn't be surprised if
that one person who appeared all right
the two times you talk to them on
discord suddenly becomes an annoying
[ __ ] who has seemingly never taught any
manners by their parents the typical
estimate on how many people you should
share accommodation with goes by taking
the width and length of a standard hotel
room calculating the area then dividing
that by the number of average human
bodies that can lay in it side by side
once you arrive at the con the first
challenge you'll have to handle is
picking up your badge this is a fairly
simple procedure for small conventions
but for any larger ones you'll need to
be ready most cons allow you to pick it
up the day before the convention starts
as if you show up on the opening day
you'll be expected to wait in line for
approximately half the life expectancy
of an average human being while also
being subjugated to walk past least 10
[ __ ] you measure the life worth on
how many high-fives they can collect and
once you get past that you can finally
start enjoying the convention if this is
your first time it may be a surreal
experience hearing words like kawaii or
Sugoi or Joe Joe reference casually
being thrown out in public and some
people take this as a sign that they've
just entered a separate dimension of
reality detached from any and all social
norms surprisingly this is not actually
the case so be sure to keep in mind that
all actions that can make you seem
creepy or rude or downright criminally
harassing in the real world still do
apply here
cosplayers are one of the most
well-known things about conventions and
you may get excited seeing some of your
favorite characters or even your waifu
though
be wary is not a widely known fact that
cosplayers have personalities emotions
insecure
tee's morals and lives outside of their
costumes so they are almost just like
human beings if you want to take a
picture the correct social etiquette are
go up to the cosplayer ask politely if
he can take a picture then awkwardly
tried to figure out where he's supposed
to put your hands if you're thinking
about cosplaying yourself however then
don't forget at the end of every
convention you will be put in a deaf
tourneys against everyone else who
cosplayed your character as only one is
allowed to walk out alive spending the
entire day at the convention can be
draining so it's recommended you bring
some kind of bag with all the provisions
you need if you want to be prepared a
rough list of things you'll need is your
con book schedule snacks camera phone
charger hand sanitizer spare batteries
poster tubes camping gear first-aid kits
obvious fiber pack pepper spray machetes
extra bullets for good luck and most
importantly enough liquids to make it
through a nuclear winter despite all
this however there will always be one
resource that is in short supply this is
body spray it is a device that can be
applied on the body which can
temporarily mask out odor and is very
commonly mistaken for a shower this is
not a shower I repeat this is not a
shower
it is however used to freshen yourself
up when taking care of your personal
hygiene
a secret technique known only to the
chosen few who attend on their arduous
journey of internally gagging every
fifth person they pass be especially
careful of any tightly packed gaming
room as such spaces can be prone to
their own independent climate with
increased humidity comparable to
tropical rainforests now that you're all
ready to enjoy the convention let's see
what's going on the most obvious is the
dealer's room which scientifically
functions as a black hole for your
wallet this is usually the busiest place
at the convention so add a big con you
can expect the walking speed to average
out at about one millimeter per hour if
you do ever find yourself in this kind
of situation it's the perfect time to
just stand around in a large group doing
nothing as it's sure to inconvenience
and annoy absolutely no one ever you may
notice one in the hall the environment
conditions you to bypass your logical
brain in order to make as many
irrational purchases as possible this
phenomenon is known as con by as high
and once infected it can only be stopped
when the individual looks at their
wallet and eventually realizes that they
aren't going to be able to pay the next
three months of rent panels are also a
massive part of conventions there will
be many different panels running but if
there is a popular panel you want to
attend
make sure you set up camp at least seven
months before the panel starts but be
wary that the line will still probably
be over capacity just before your turn
can range from many different topics and
shows and a lot of them allow you to ask
questions if he ever wanted more insight
once the panel was nearing its end it's
not any time for the Quickfire questions
to get through as many people as they
can
unfortunately even if you have a burning
insightful question nobody has asked yet
this is the time which guarantees the
next person will take up 15 minutes
asking the panelists what brand of
shampoo they use that morning other
important areas you can check out is the
artist alley where you'll buy call it
shrinkage you're losing a day the gaming
room where you'll get your ass kicked by
at least 10 different people more
practice than you and the main lobby
where you can hang out in crowd watch
and definitely not judge the 50 people
walking past you who shouts our dead
meme as you'll be having so much fun and
wanting to spend as much time at the con
as possible normal living habits may
become somewhat of a nuisance that takes
time away from things you want to do
case in point
food food will turn from part of your
daily routine to something you'll have
to consciously consider where you'll be
surviving the weekend on a standard
dietary recommendation of pizza burger
instant ramen and chips now though this
is the recommended diet you'll find that
often times you have to make an
important choice between going to that
one events you plan to and eating one is
a panel of sweaty nerves talking about
cartoons and the other is your normal
daily routine that every human needs in
order to get energy and survive so now
that you've gone two days without eating
a meal you may feel your body shutting
down and you need to find a place to eat
this could be the right time to venture
further outside the convention to find
the proper restaurants be warned however
as the further away you venture from the
venue the closer you are to normal
society again which can be deadly for
any con goer luckily this is something
you can calculate as if you open up
google maps and mark off the area around
the convention the weave density is
inversely proportionate to the distance
traveled away from the convention in
miles this is known as the wee Boltzmann
law and this area marked off right here
is the safe zone unless of course your
city has an area with a high
concentration of Japanese or Korean
restaurants in which case they become
temporary embassies for weebs in times
of trouble as you'll likely be going in
a group is improbable that you'll be
able to convince everyone to go for a
healthy meal option so if you want to
eat healthy during the convention then
my best advice to you is you're [ __ ]
on some rare occasions the convention
may be held at the hotel or venue when
normal people are stained which can end
up becoming one of those unintentionally
amusing things watching them trying to
figure out exactly what new planet
they've just woken up on
if this happens don't be afraid to show
them that we are just normal people say
hi ask them what they do for a living
what they're here for and which one of
the Monica tree girls they'd prefer to
have sit on them if you want a packet in
early note that there are probably
activities still going on after hours
many conventions hold raves a place
where you either get to see a large
group of awkward anime fans bouncing
around and clapping or people who are
confident enough to try dancing by
attempting to waterbend this is not to
be confused with idol shows which is the
only place in universe you'll be able to
see a concert hall full of anime nerds
go absolutely [ __ ] mental for many
others however after-hours activities
will just boil down to finding a place
to consume enough alcohol to poison the
[ __ ] elephants once you've gone
through all that congratulations you
have survived and hopefully enjoyed your
anime convention now comes the hardest
part the post Kon you know that story
you always hear about people waking up
from their hangovers after a hard night
of drinking and feeling like death when
they see the sunlight well it's a bit
like that except the hangover is your
post Kon blues and the sunlight is the
crippling depression you feel when you
realize that you're back in normal
society you can't shout out memes
casually everyone's wearing boring
normal clothes and nobody wants your
free hugs anymore
actually maybe no-one ever wanted your
free hugs stop trying to give me free
hugs
I don't want free hugs get out of my
personal space that's the typical con
experience after a long weekend of anime
you may find it takes some time to
rehabilitate yourself back into society
but once you do you will realize that
despite all the possible shortcomings
you had an absolutely fantastic time and
you want to go to as many conventions as
possible only to forget that your wallet
had already put out a hit on you as you
don't have any money to pay next month's
rent because of that bigger in you
bought you stupid anime trash
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month - hi Joe
Leon basil Lee Watts
Patrick Madsen and everyone else on
patreon for helping to support me for
this month and making this video
possible sorry it's been a while since I
uploaded by I do have a reason I swear
to God
so last month I must have hit my head or
something and I thought it would be a
good idea to work on - yes - anime and
minutes episodes at once both which take
a [ __ ] ton of time by themselves and of
course I couldn't have picked a worse
time since I just got hit by the not
advertiser friendly train and a lot of
my videos are D monetized so um yeah
that's a a skewed I'm not panicking
though as with all your continued
support on patreon I should be able to
make it through this so if you are
interested in supporting the channel you
click on the button below or the links
in the description but aside from that I
have no further updates
I've been gig ugh and I'll see you all
next time